welcome back we're not gonna start
Section eight and test four and let's
start with problem number one problem
number one if three times n minus four
is equal to 18 what is n and is equal to
what most divide both sides by 3 you get
n minus four is equal to six add 4 to
both sides you get N equals 10 and that
is choice D problem number two right
it's divided by well you know what I did
hopefully you know what I did two for
class ring each senior can choose from
four types of stones and three types of
metals four stones and three metals how
many combinations of a stone and metal
are there well for each stone they can
pick 3 different metals right so there's
4 because there's 4 different types of
stones and each of them can have 3
different metals so it's 4 times 3
combinations combinations which is
choice D next problem 3 if you ever
doubt yourself on like the first one or
two problems cuz it seems too easy
you probably shouldn't doubt yourself
because the first couple of problems
tend to be reasonably straightforward
I was just doubting myself goes like
this was I missing something all right
from number three the sum of three a and
the square root of B the sum of three a
plus the square root of B is equal to is
equal is equal to the square of the sum
of a and B so it's equal to the square
the square of the sum of a and B which
of the following is an expression for
the statement above oh I just wrote it
out
it's choice B but hopefully as I talked
it out you see Seuss
you saw what I was doing I said the sum
of three a so the sum of three a and the
square root of B this is the sum of
three a the square root of B is equal to
the sum of a plus B squared or they said
equal to the square of
some of a plus B next problem problem
for Carrie has a cordless telephone
receiver that can operate within a range
of 1,000 feet 1,000 foot range from the
telephones base Kerry takes the receiver
from the base and walks 800 feet due
north so this is the base and I don't
have carries a boy or girl's name but
Carrie walked 800 foot feet due north
from that point she walks due east and
stops at the maximum range of the
receiver so then she walks east and she
stops at the maximum range of the
receiver in which of the following
directions can carry walk and still be
within range of the receiver so the
range is essentially if you can go a
thousand feet from this point B right
and actually let me draw it as a circle
so I can go at most so let me let me
draw a circle here so this is and let's
say that this is the point B this is the
point B that's the base Carrie let's say
it carries a guy Carrie can get at most
a thousand feet away from the receiver
so the the furthest distance if Carrie
can get from the receiver is a thousand
feet so this radius right here is a
thousand feet and in the problem Carrie
walks 800 feet due north so maybe -
right right there
all right that's 800 and then walks due
east due east to the range of the
receiver so then walks east which is
this direction so let's do these two the
range of the receiver which is right
there
and what they want to know is in which
of the fondants can carry walk and still
be in range of the receiver well we know
Carrie can't walk north because then he
or she will be out of range receiver
can't walk east
it'll be range of receiver but he or she
can walk south or can walk back west
right so can't walk south or west and
those are choices two and three which is
choice E choice E is two and three which
is due south or due west the can walk
this way south or
West that way next problem oh whoops
problem 5 if X over 4 is equal to 2x
over a and X does not equal 0 what is
the value of a well we can divide both
sides by X because we know X doesn't
equal 0 because you can't divide by 0 so
this and this would cancel out right
we're dividing both sides by X so you
get 1/4 is equal to 2 over a and you
know you could you could eyeball this or
if you want to do it mathematically you
could say 1 times a is equal to 4 times
2 which is 8 now you can said well you
know - over what - is 1/4 of what number
well it's 8 so a is equal to 8 choice a
problem number 6 and we have a little
drawing here to do see you problem
number 6 so you have a parallel line
like that I should I don't know they're
probably add cuz they haven't told me
but it kind of looks like that although
I shouldn't assume a transversal if
those are parallel let me switch colors
ok so they're saying this angle right
here is our this is U s T and this is
line L this is line m in the figure
above L is parallel to M so L and M are
parallel I was right and R is 50 degrees
so R is equal to 50 degrees what is the
value of S Plus T plus u well what are
the angles that are corresponding to R
if R is 50 the corresponding angle here
so kind of that you know the same if you
don't remember this you might want to
review the the geometry module where I
did this the corresponding angle here is
U and so this angle is also going to be
equal to 50 degrees let me do a
different color so that equals 50 and
that's cuz they kind of take the same
role where the transversal intersects
the proa lines and if this is 50 this is
the opposite angle right so that is also
going to be that angle is also going to
be 50
and T and you are supplementary right so
T plus you are gonna be 180 or you could
say that this is 130 all right so what's
50 plus 50 plus 130 it's a hundred plus
130 it's 230 degrees which is choice a
next problem
third colors problem number seven and
the XY coordinate plane line L is
perpendicular to the y axis and point
and passes to the point 5 negative 3 so
let me so those are my axes Y X and this
line I'll draw it in green it passes a
point 5 negative 3 so that's like here
someplace and it's perpendicular to the
y axis is the y axis is perpendicular to
it so it forms a 90 degree angle and we
know this it's a 90 degree angle and it
passes to the point 5 and the - you know
- 3 - 3 so this is a point right here
this is 5 minus 3 which of the following
is an equation of the line l okay well
what is the slope of this it's a flat
line it's it's it's flat line for as
much as you run as much as you have a
change in X there's no change in Y right
so the slope is 0 and what's the
y-intercept the y-intercept is where you
intersect the y axis well you're going
to intersect it y equals negative 3 so B
is minus 3 and if you don't that's I'm
saying this from the form y equals MX
plus B is a slope of a line M is 0 B is
3 so we know the slope is y equals
negative 3 that's the equation y equals
negative 3 that's choice C and in
general you know if you just drew this
line you're like well no matter what X
is y is equal to negative 3 and you said
well that's the equation y is equal to
negative 3
I have a minute left I don't think
that's enough time to do a problem it
might be but I don't want to rush things
so I'll do the next problem in the next
video I'll see you soon